hi everybody it's kevin Van Ord here
standing in for reviewer Nick Kappa
solely to give you our updated review of
arma 3 arma threes campaign was released
piecemeal over the last few months with
its final act landing in March
ultimately it wasn't worth the wait
given the campaign's inconsistent
mission quality threadbare plot and
groan inducing voice acting take a left
at the t-junction and Kari do try not to
make roadkill of the local wildlife the
green banks already hate our guts we
need to at least keep the goat
population on side you copy that soldier
minimize collateral damage certain
hearts and mine sir luckily the rest of
the game still carries its share of the
weight and it's online and in the user
created scenarios that ARMA 3 busts free
of the campaign's constraints
but a campaign was promised and it has
been delivered NATO forces are in the
midst of a drawdown on the island of
Stratis when the once friendly local
forces lash out in a surprise attack a
multi-stage affair ensues in three
stages called survive adapt and win you
as one corporal carry take on an
escalating part in an escalating war
eventually graduating from a follower
role on stratasys meager 20 square
kilometers two commanding a squad on
Altis and it's staggering 270 square
kilometers there are a few vague
allusions to an overarching plot but the
story is relegated to simple background
noise the campaign is a strange beast
torn between the tedium of real warfare
and the Hollywood bombast of well modern
warfare the game sends you lumbering
across the hills and valleys of Altis
for miles without encountering anything
worth firing around that then an
electric guitar wails a helicopter
starts draping your position and you're
forced to bug out at the same ponderous
pace that you entered with seconds ago
the fractured nature of ARMA 3's
campaign makes for an uneven experience
at best but that variability does have
an accentuating effect when things fall
into a more natural stride for one
there's a real fragility to Kerry in his
unit the introduction of the island of
Altis is another high point presenting a
rigorous mission that sees Kerry
attempting to rearm and regroup after
being stranded behind enemy lines
when ARMA 3 forgets its half-baked tale
of black ops intrigue and leans on the
more tangible drama of a botched rescue
it simmers and then erupts in ways most
shooters can't alter machine-gunner 75
metres behind us
in the campaign and outside of it
there's no room for mistakes when you're
this fragile you might succumb to razor
accurate shots fired by enemies in
distant Hills even when they aren't
equipped with scopes and many of these
instances are learning experiences at
other times like when your gun down
because you've opened the map when the
game told you to death doesn't always
feel fair in either case you need to pay
constant attention and master the
finicky controls which lend the combat a
certain amount of gravitas most modern
shooters grants an athletic flourish to
the act of killing here the satisfaction
of downing an enemy comes from the
knowledge that he won't be shooting at
you anymore not in how a jointly you had
shot at him though ARMA 3's campaign may
be a bit of a dud the rest of the game
remains more than capable of carrying a
payload there are the package showcases
which introduced the game's more varied
weapons vehicles and techniques in
isolation there's a firing range that
offers a bit of shooting gallery style
diversion what's of more significance is
the multiplayer one good session is
worth trawling the server browser for a
little while it's a blast to leapfrog
between bits of cover and to suite
buildings with a collective conscience
that are still is the library of mods
packed with thousands of player created
variants that run the gamut from rally
races to dynamic war simulations you can
take on a gauntlet of snipers attempt a
recreation of the real-life Neptune
spear mission and explore wasteland the
survivalist affair that highlights ARMA
3's talents for brooding deliberate
engagements or you could simply wander
the islands grabbing a few pictures to
put alongside the town's salt flats and
castles that litter the maps expansive
topography in any direction you go
there's loosely structured fun to be had
in light of the disappointing campaign
you're best off taking those hills on
your own or with friends and creating
your own kind of warfare
you